[موسيقى]
من اقصى الشرق الى بلادما وراء المحيطات
استقر ضيفي في المنفى بحثا عن الحريه كانت
له اختيارته السياسيه وكان يؤمن باختيار
السياسي على غرار باقي المناضلين الذين لا
تراه الا يستمعوا الى الاخرين
ويتاملوا فيما يقولونه
ويتخذوا الموقيف الذي يراه
ملائما بالنسبه له شخصيا لم افاجا بالمال
الذي انتهى اليه مساره
[موسيقى]
لم يكن مسارا سهلا لكن بخطى واثقه مضى نحو
المستقبل رافضا القيود مؤمنا بنصيبه
بالتحرر من الاستبداد وقدرته على ان يكون
جسرا لحريه الاخرين
هو اولا تعتاقلوها ولا زال شابا صغيرا
ربما الى
عنده اقل من 20 سنه وهو التجربه ديال
الاعتقال
تعاطى معها
بمواجهه يعني بحيث تحمل التابعات ديال
الاعتقال ديال
[موسيقى]
هو من تنقل حاملا في جعبته ملفات ازمات
ومشاورات الحل هنا او هناك حتى تربع على
عرش مفاوضات تعد الاكثر تعقيدا
انا ولدت في مدينه الناظور لكن العائله هي
من اقليم الحسيمه والدي هو من بني وريال
عشت طفوله هادئه جدا في اسره كانت تؤكد
على ضروره التربيه الاطفال تربيه ليست
محافظه لكن
التربيه متفتحه جدا
لاربعه اخوات انت الاوسط انا الاوسط اكيد
لكن الاوسط يعني معناها انه
تعلمت منذ الطفوله الاعتماد على النفس
مع اخوانك كيف كانت علاقتك باخوانك
العلاقه كانت حميمه جدا ولا زالت لكن لم
اتذكر طفولتي اتذكر الجده كانت ام والدتي
كانت تعيش معنا في المنزل انتقلنا من
الناظور الى مدينه اخرى مدينه مدينه تطوان
وعيشت فتره المراهقه هناك في مدينه تطوان
قبل
ان التحقت بالجامعه
انذاك في الرباط العاصمه
تنتمي الى عائله عرف عنها النضال ما الذي
زرعته فيك يعني بماذا تاثرت جدي
شارك في
جمهوريه الريف وكان من اقرب
المعاونين لعبد الكريم الخطابي بطل حرب
الريف كان هو المسؤول ان ذلك جدي على جميع
القضايا الماليه بالنسبه للجمهوريه كذلك
والد التحق بجيش التحرير جيش عبد الكريم
الخطابي وعمره 15 سنه هذا يعني اثر عليه
طبعا كون ان اعرف هذا التاريخ النضالي
للعائله
لكن جاءت
سنه 65 كانت هناك انتفاضه قمعت في المغرب
كان كذلك تذكر اختطاف المهدي بن بركه كان
زعيم المعارضه لكن جاءت احداث اخرى هزيمه
ومن بعد الحركه الطلابيه 68 في فرنسا
الثوره الفيتناميه
الى التوجه السياسي وانت على مقاعد
الدراسه كم كان عمرك سنه بدات اهتم
بالسياسه لماذا اخترت اليسار اخترت اليسار
لان كنا يعني نعتقد على انه الحركه
الوطنيه حققت يعني نجاح يعني بالحصول على
الاستقلال
نجاح نسبي لكن فشلت يعني في
الدفع بالديمقراطيه في المغرب وكان انا
ذاك الحكم كان حكم مطلق وكانت
الاحزاب التقليديه غير قادره على الدفع
بحركه التغيير بشكل عام ولهذا كجميع
الشباب في العالم العربي بدانا نتجه نحو
ما سميناه اليسار الجديد
الى الامام يعني حركه واسعه حركه شبابيه
في الحقيقه اللي كانت حركه ثوريه التي
تاثرت كثيرا بالماركسيه وكانت حركه سلميه
ولكن جوبح
تني
بالاعتقال والترهيب كان لي شرف كبير شرف
الانتماء لهذه الحركه وانا اظن هذه الحركه
كانت هي السبب الرئيسي اللي غير نسبيا
ووضع الحريات في المغرب الان
[موسيقى]
انت ما اكل هذه الحركه كان السبب
والاعتالك هل تذكر لحظه الاعتقال وتفاصيل
الاعتقال وما التهمه التي وجهت اليك في
سنه في يناير
وكنت طالب في كليه الحقوق في الرباط اعتقد
الالاف تم اختطافي في وقت متاخر بالليل
وتم اغتياد الى مخفر للشرطه في الرباط
وعدبت الليله يعني هذه ليله تسعه يناير لن
انساها
كان تعذيب رهيب لكن ما اتذكره كذلك هو لما
تم اختيادي الى معتقل سري مشهور في المغرب
يسمى معتقل للشريف كنت معصوم العينين مكبل
اليدين ودام هذا لمده شهور ونقضيت ثمانيه
سنوات في السجن معظم السنوات قضيتها في
زنزانه انفراديه هل تابعه صوره رجال الامن
لا لن انسى ابدا انما حصل خلال هذه المده
يعني كان كان التجربه رهيبه جدا
[موسيقى]
يعني اضراب في اطار سلسله من الاضطرابات
على الطعام
الذي خطناه انذاك
الاضراب الاول كان المطالبه بمحاكمه تحديد
موعد للمحاكمه
وتستمر هذا الاضراب لمده 17 يوم الاضراب
الثاني كان الاحتجاج على ان المحاكمه كانت
محاكمه غير عادله واستمر هذا الاضراب لمده
19 يوم وفعلا يعني نتيجه هذه الاضرابات
تحسنت الاوضاع ان المعيشيه في السجن تلقيت
خبر وفاه والدك لتلك الفتره كيف كان وقع
الخبر عليك الوقت كان رهيب جدا لانه والدي
كان بصحه جيده
زارني بالسجن المركزي بالقنيطره
ومن بعد اسبوعين
توصل بهذا الخبر الصاعقه على انه فجاه
توفى طبعا لم تسمح لاداره السجن السلطات
المغربيه برؤيته الى اخر مره
في الجنازه اتاثر عليه بشكل
بشكل كبير هل تذكر اخر حديث دار بينك وبين
الوالد عندما زارك لاخر مره قبل ان يتوفى
نعم لازلت اتذكر بالتفاصيل الوالد كان
يتكلم على كون انه شارك في النضال ضد
الاستعمار لكن في نهايه المطاف عملاء
الاستعمار واعوانهم هم استفادوا من
الاستقلال وليس الذين ناضلوا من اجل
الجلاء الاستعمار من المغرب وكان يقول
اتمنى ان نضالكم سيؤدي الى نتيجه الى
المغرب افضل مما نحن فيه
الاعتقال والسجناء عن اكمال تعليمك حصلت
على البكالوريوس والماجستير وانت في
المعتقل صحيح لما تحسنت اوضاعنا
ان المعيش في السجن
كانت من بين البطاله بالسماح لنا بمتابعه
الدراسه
وفعلا حصلت على البكالوريوس في هنا في
السجن
وبدات يعني وتسجلت في
جامعتين مختلفتين في فرنسا
وحصلت على الماجستير الاول والماجستير
الثاني وبدات يعني احضر اطروحه دكتوره كيف
تصف تجربه السجن ككل في الحقيقه كانت
التجربه غنيه فريده من نوعها
عشت مع مجموعه المعتقلين السياسيين كان
137 كانت دائما حلقات نقاش مناظرات
اجتماعات حاولنا تنظيم وقتنا في السجن
بشكل يسمح لنا اننا نتابع الدراسه
في السجن ثمان سنوات كيف تم الافراج عنك
اولا كانت هناك حمله تضامن معي ومع
المعتقلين سياسي
انه تم تبنينا من طرف منظمه العرف الدوليه
كسجنه رايي السبب المباشر كان هو تدخل
الاستاذ كان سيشرف على اطروحه الدكتوره
نحضرها بدات في تحضيرها في هنا في السجن
اسمه
كان عاش في المغرب وكان استاذ الملك
الراحل الملك الحسن الثاني تدخل واستجاب
الملك لطلبه كانت مفاجاه لي انني خرجت يوم
23 نوفمبر 83 ما اول شيء قمت بفعله عندما
افرج عنك اولا توجهت الى منزل الوالده
كانت مفاجاه
انه تم اطلاق سراحي زرت المقبره كان يوجد
فيها والدي للترحم عليه هذا كان اول
شيء فكرت فيه يعني مباشره بعد خروج من
السجن
[موسيقى]
المعاناه في السجن كانت قاسيه جدا
كذلك عائلتنا اعانت يعني بشكل كبير
تصور والدتي والده لم يكن يعرف مكان
اعتقالي لما تم اختطافه
لمده شهور كذلك خلال 8 سنوات والدتي ساهمت
في عدد من المظاهرات والاحتجاجات اللي
كانوا يقوم بها عائلات المعتقلين السياسي
مجددا بعد الافراج ما الاسباب تم اعتقالي
لانه في يناير اربعه وثمانين كانت هناك
انتفاضه في عدد من المدن في المغرب
بالخصوص في الشمال وانا كنت شاهد لما حصل
بالخصوص في مدينه تطوان حين اطلق الجيش
الرصاص على متظاهرين سلميين وسقط العديد
من الضحايا هذه الانتفاضه كانت عفويه لم
نكن منظمه من اي فصيل وطرف سياسي لكن كان
نظام يريد ان يلصق تهمه التامر مره اخرى
لكل ما هو معروف يعني انه هو له سوابق
نضاليه تم اعتقالي في هذا في هذا الاطار
مده اعتقال كانت ثلاث اسابيع تدخلت عدد من
منظمات الدوليه منظمات حقوق الانسان
المطالبه باطلاق سراحي وتم اطلاق سراحي
حظا دعني اقول او الاوفر حظا بعلم
المنظمات الدوليه بحالك
وبناء عليه تم الافراج عنك ربما لو لم تكن
هذه المنظمات على درايه مما يحصل لكان
مصيرك مختلف تماما هذا صحيح فعلا كون ان
كانت لي علاقات
مع منظمه العفو الدوليه ومنظمه حقوق
الانسان في الخارج هذا كان عامل مساعد
اكيد حاولت الحصول على جواز سفر لكنك لم
تتمكن يعني رفضت السلطات ان تعطيك حتى
جواز السفر خوفا من خروجك او سفرك خارج
البلاد نعم انا فكرت في ذاك الوقت انه
وجودي في المغرب اصبح يعني
صعب ولهذا فضلت مغادره المغرب بطريقه غير
شرعيه بدون اي بدون جواز سفر
عبر البحر الى اسبانيا فعلا غادرت المغرب
اتخذت هذا القرار وانا اشعر بمراره خرجت
بالمغرب يعني في قارب صيد
وكانت رحله صعبه وخطيره لكن تمكنت من
الوصول الى
الضفه الاخرى
وصلت الى اسبانيا كانت تعاملهم ايجابي جدا
وتمكنت يعني من مغادره اسبانيا في اتجاهه
في اتجاه لندن وصلت الى لندن بدون جواز
سفر لكن الواقع النفسي هذا الرحله كان صعب
جدا لانه هو تغادر بلدك بدون اي فكره على
في اي وقت ممكن الرجوع
لازلت اتذكر القارب قارب الصيد يبتعد يعني
من الضفه يتحد من الشاطئ شيئا فشيئا الى
ان دخلنا في عمق البحر
ويعني المجهول شعرت بكابه رغم تضحياتنا من
اجل المغرب افضل لا اضطررت يعني يعني
لمهادره بلدي هل حرقت كل شيء
يعني لما خرجت من المغرب تمكنت يعني من
القيام بحمله كبيره يعني هذه الحمله التي
ادت في نهايه المطاف الى اجبار السلطات
لاطلاق صالح جميع المعتقلين السياسيين
[موسيقى]
نحو مستقبل لا يشبه الماضي ولان لكل نهايه
بدايه لم تنطفئ احلام بن عمر على شواطئ
المنفى اذ غذا مدافعا عن حقوق الانسان حيث
كانت البدايه مع منظمه العفو الدوليه
اول نشاط لك بعد خروجك من المغرب كان
الانضمام الى منظمه العفو الدوليه لماذا
هذه المنظمه لم استقريت في لندن
[موسيقى]
قررت القيام بجوله في العالم لشرح ما يجري
في المغرب
وكان هذا التحرك يعني بالتنسيق مع عدد من
المنظمات الحقوقيه بما فيها منظمه العفو
الدوليه من بعد التحقت
بمنظمه العفو الدوليه في
بطاقه الدولي الموجود في في لندن
وكلفت
بملف
الدراسات والابحاث فيما يخص
الدول الافريقيه عام 1990 التقيت في
الرئيس الامريكي السابق جميل كارتير
والتحقت بمعهد السلام العالمي وايضا عينك
هو كمستشار خاص له ما سر هذه الثقه كانت
تجربه مهمه جدا لانه تعلمت اشياء كثيره
لما تعمل بجانب الراي السابق اول شيء
تعلمته الخصوصيات النظام السياسي الامريكي
بتعقيداته فهمت هذا وهذا ساعدني بشكل
كبير فيما بعد عن طريقه تعرفت على المرحوم
الملك حسين تعرفت على ان يرسم مانديلا
وساعه نصر المنديله في اول جوله قام بها
في الامم المتحده العمل مع جيمي وهذا
العدد من العلاقات الذي كان متاحا لك هل
ساهم بشكل او باخر لوصولك الى منصب نائب
امين او المتحده اكيد هذيك التجربه مهمه
استفدت منها لان احنا في مركز كارتر كنا
نشتغل على عدد من القضايا
حساسه ولكن قضايتهم الامم المتحده طبعا
وكنت اتي من اطلانتا الى نيويورك للقاء مع
بطرس غالي في مكتبه
لاطلعه على ما نقوم به من انشطه الى اخره
لما التحقت الامم المتحده التحقت بمركز
حقوق الانسان اللي كان انذاك موجود في
جنيف انا كنت مكلف
بتطوير برامج وانشطه في الميدان وفي هذا
السياق فتحنا عدد من المكاتب في عدد من
الدول بعد خمس سنوات اصبح لنا اكثر من 50
مشروع في اكثر من خمسين دوله
داخل الاروقه الامم المتحده وهل صحيح من
خلال هذا النفوذ تصديت للوفد المغربي في
التسعينيات رغم صدور عفو عما يعرف بسنوات
الرصاص كنت سبب بخروجهم المتحده كنت في
مقر المتحده في جنيف
ولاحظت ان هناك فيه وفد رسمي وفد مغربي
موجود لتقديم تقرير المغرب للجنه المتعلقه
بمناهضه التعذيب
لكن تفاجات لما شفت من بين اعضاء الوفد
[موسيقى]
الجلاد الشهير
اللي اسمه اليوسفي قدور هذا هو كان مدير
والمسؤول على المعتقل السري اللي عشت فيه
يعني عده شهور في الدار البيضاء لهذا يعني
توجهت للمسؤولين في الامم المتحده او
الصحافه او الاعلام واخبرتهم بما يجري
شهرت بهذا الجلاد وكان من حقه نقوم بهذا
وفعلا كانت هذه فضيحه
تم طرده فورا فعلا
وتقدم المغرب انذاك باعتذار رسم الامم
المتحده
[موسيقى]
كنت اظن الفريق الاممي بقياده الاخضر
الابراهيمي الذي كلف بتاسيس افغانستان ما
بعد الغزو عام 2001 ما الدور الذي لعبته
في هذا الملف انا قضيت خمس سنوات في مركز
الانسان اللي سميت فيما بعد مفوضيه العامه
والانسان في بعد انتقلت لنيويورك وكنت من
الاطر
البرنامج الانمائي لما بدات ازمه
افغانستان شكل الامين العام فريق
يضم جميع منظمات الامم المتحده كنت من ضمن
هذه المجموعه التي قدمت
مقترحات واراء اولا فيما يخص
المرحله الانتقاليه
التي عرفتها الافغانستان وكذلك يعني وهذا
ما ركزت عليه موضوع الحكم الرشيد موضوع
الاصلاحات المؤسساتيه
وكذلك موضوع سيارات الدستور وبناء القضاء
مستقل لكن كان رايي في ذاك الوقت لما
التقيت مع الطالبان مع بدايه الحرب على
افغانستان
واكتشفت انهم لهم رهبه في المساهمه في
بناء افغانستان الجديد
للعالم يتكلم عليه كان فيه اجتماع نحن في
الامم المتحده نحضر له في المانيا كانوا
يريدون المشاركه في هذا الاجتماع لكن لما
نقلت هذا لعدد من الزملاء كان الجواب وانه
هذا مستحيل بالنسبه للاداره الامريكيه
يعني بالنسبه لهم الطالبان
اي طالبا يجب ان يكون يجب ان يقتل او يسجن
في في
طالبان انتهوا نهائيا ما كان رايي مخالف
في ذاك الوقت وانه طالب انه جزء لا يتجزا
يعني من المجتمع ما رايك بسيطره طالبان
اليوم على افغانستان هذا الدليل انه
المشروع الامريكي ولا مشروع الغرب في
افغانستان كان من الاحرار ان يتم الحوار
مع الطالبان منذ منذ البدايه يعني 2002
حتى يكون جزء من الحل هذا لم يتم
ولم يستطيع الامريكيون ان يبنوا هذه
الديمقراطيه الذي كانوا يتصدقون بها يعني
انه الديمقراطي لا يمكن ان تبنى الا من
خلال الجهد محلي وطني وليس يعني بدافع من
الخارج
[موسيقى]
من افغانستان الى العراق حيث اشرفت على
اعداد وتنصيب اول حكومه في ظل الاحتلال
الامريكي وهي حكومه برئاسه اياد علاوي هل
كان دور الامم المتحده دورا واضحا وحقيقيا
ام دورا شكلي لاعطاء او اطفاء شرعيه على
اول حكومه في ظل الاحتلال متحده كنا نسعى
للعب دور دور فعلي حقيقي لكن بالنسبه
الامريكان اكيد كانوا يريدون استعمال
الامم المتحده كمظله لاطفاء شرعيا او كان
هناك تناقض وكان هناك صراع يعني احيانا
وانتقدت سنه بشكل واضح وصريح السياسه
الامريكيه هناك
بالخصوص حل الجيش وقصه شيسات البعث وكذلك
الحمله اتذكر لما كنت هناك في العراق في
2004 كانت هناك حمله على
اتباع مقتدى الصدر
في النجف
وقتل المئات من شباب كان موقفي واضح بذاك
الوقت وانه يجب الحوار مع هذه التيارات
اللي هي مناهضه لوجود الامريكي ادى هذا
التناقض يعني هذا الصراع مع السياسات
الامريكيه انتقادي لهم الى منع من الرجوع
العراق في نهايه 2004 رغم هذا يعني في
2007 طلب مني التواصل مع عدد من الحركات
المسلحه اللي كانت تناهد الامريكان يعني
بقوه السلاح
من الذي طلب منك ذلك الامريكان والانجليز
طلبوا من الامن العام المتحده ان اعود
للعراق للتواصل مع هذه المجموعات بهدف
ايجاد صيغه لقبولهم العمل بشكل سلمي في
العمليه السياسيه
وفي هذا السياق تواصلت مع عدد من القيادات
هذه الحركات المسلحه
وحاولنا اقناعهم لكن المشكله كانت مع
الامريكان كنت اقترح عليهم ان يحددوا جدول
زمني لمغادرتهم للعراق وهمم يكونوا لم
يكونوا قابلين بهذا الاقتراح يعني في
نهايه المطاف بعد التضحيات كثيره وقتله
بالمئات بالالاف
قبل الامريكان هذه الفكره لكن
ضع وقت ثمين هذا غير معروف لم نتكلم عنه
فعلا التقيت يعني بشكل سري
مع عدد من هذه القيادات التي كانت تقول
الحركه المسلحه ضد
كان موقفناته انه هو فعلا هناك جزء لا امل
فيه هو القاعده هادو ارهابيين
لا مستقبل لهم يعني لكن فيه مجموعه اخرى
التشات للسلاح التشات للعنف لانه كان يظن
على الامريكان سيبقى في العراق للابد
هادو ناس حركتهم الوطنيه وليس يعني شيء
اخر
كنا نقترح ان يكون تواصل
ما بينهم ما بين الحكومه العراقيه
هذا كان صعب كانوا لا يعيدوا التواصل مع
الحكومه العراقيه كذلك كنا نقترح ان يكون
ان يتواصلوا مع
الاداره الامريكيه ان يكون في مفاوضه من
اجل ايجاد صيغه للحل يعني كلها تقوم على
فكره
الانسحاب الامريكي تدريجيا من العراق
[موسيقى]
هل دورك انحصر في تنصيب الحكومات واعداد
الدساتير في مرحله ما بعد الغزو كان دورنا
ودارت دور الميسر
وبطلب مجلس الامن والفطار
قرارات مجلس الامن انا اتذكر ان وضعت اول
لائحه والمسوده للائحه الوزراء
نتذكر انه 80% من مقترحات التي قدمها تم
قبولها ما عدا يعني المناصب المهمه مثل
رئيس الوزراء او الدفاع او الداخليه هذه
كان فيها جدل لكن كيف يعقل ان تاتي الامم
المتحده من خارج العراق يعني لكي تقترح
حكومه يعني في في بلد مثل هذا ما هي
المخاوف التي كانت تساور في تلك المرحله
اكبر مشكله كانت في ذاك الوقت هي السياسه
الامريكيه السياسه الامريكيه في العراق
كانت خاطئه جدا لدرجه انه في نهايه 2004
امريكان يعني بشكل رسمي طلبه من كوفي عنان
عدم الرجوع الى العراق الاداره الامريكيه
راضيه عن ويبدو ان الشارع العراقي لم يكن
ايضا يعني راضيا عن ما تقدمه الامم
المتحده او عن نشاطها في الداخل العراقي
بدليل عام 2003 تعرضتم لمحاوله اغتيال هذه
كانت عمليه ارهابيه
هدفها هو
زعزعه الاستقرار في
العراق وقف العمليه السياسيه في العراق
وانهاء جميع الجهود الراميه الى بناء عراق
ديمقراطي جديد الدخول في عمليه انتخابيه
بناء دستور جديد
مكتوب باقلام عراقيه وليس
دستور يملا من الخارج كما كان يعني مخطط
له يعني في الاداره الامريكيه يعني
المنظمه المتحده في نهايه المطاف يعني
تروج للديمقراطيه لكن ليست هي منظمه
ديمقراطي يعني الدول الخمسه الدول دائمه
العضويه هي لهم السلطه يعني في في مجلس
الامن
[موسيقى]
وسط نيران الحروب والازمات وجد بن عمر
نفسه مبعوثا امنيا كان عليه ان يسير بحذر
بين اطراف الصراع محاولا نزعفه لازمه
تتصاعد في شرق ملتهب لا تلتئم جراحه ملف
اليمن كان ثالث الازمات التي حاول بن عمر
ان يطرح اوراق الحل لها لكنها تبعثرت
مع بدايه الربيع العربي ثورات الربيع
العربي كنت المستشار في الامم المتحده
الذي يقدم المشوره الامين العام والدائره
السياسيه في الامم المتحده حول كيفيه
التعامل مع هذه الاحداث لكن صراع كان محتد
في اليمن وكان هناك تخوف عندي مجتمع
الدولي بشكل عام وفي مجلس الامن ان الوضع
في اليمن ممكن ان ينفجر
كحرب اهليه في هذا السياق طلب مني الامن
العام
نتكلم بهذه المهمه وزرت اليمن حين قبلت
بهذه المهمه ما هي اول خطوه اتخذتها
التقيت مع الرئيس
سابق عليها عبد الله صالح
التقيت مع
القيادات الاحزاب التقليديه كلها
[موسيقى]
التقيت كذلك مع الشباب الذين كانوا في
الساحه وكان هذا شيء جديد بالنسبه لهم ان
يزورهم
[موسيقى]
مبعوث الامم المتحده
التقيت معهم
وتوصلت الى قناه على انه
مطالبهم مشروعه رايت الشباب تواخ للحريه
للعداله للكرامه
اليمن جديد ديمقراطي
انهاء حكم العائله والعشيره والسلاله
كان كانت هذه المطالب كلها مشروعها كان
المهم هو كيفيه يعني تحويل هذه المطالب
الى عمليه سياسيه يشارك فيها جميع
اليمنيين هذا كان المعضله سانقل للعالم
مره اخرى صوره عن مشهد يمني حضاري خبرناه
طيله الفتره الماضيه
كنت موجود في صنعاء كيف سيطر الحوثي على
صنعاء الحوثيون يعني شاركوا في مؤتمر
الحوار الوطني
كما شاركت جميع الاطراف في السياسيه
وناكدت في ذلك الوقت على مشاركه الشباب
والمراه بعد الاتفاق على هذه المخرجات كان
هناك يعني من طرف الطرف الدوله من طرف
الرئاسه ومن طرف الحكومه لتنفيذ عدد من
المخرجات لم يكن هناك اتفاق على الصيغه
النهائيه لليمن الاتحادي كان هناك خلاف
على عدد الاقاليم والجغرافيه هذه الاقاليم
مع الاسف الاخ الرئيس
فرض بصيغه كانت مرفوضه عند الجنوبيين
ومرفوضه عند الحوثيين هي صيغه سته اقاليم
الحوثيون انذاك ظنوا على انه سيتم حصرهم
في منطقه جبليه
[موسيقى]
ليست لها اي
موارد طبيعيه ومن لا منفذ على البحر الى
اخره الجنوبيون كذلك يعني رفضوا هذا
التقطيع الجغرافي لانه كانوا يريده يعني
على الاقل
الجنوب كاقليم واحد اشكاليه الثانيه انه
مؤتمر الحوار الوطني
اكد على ضروره الشراكه في الحكومه
الحكومه انذاك كانت مشكله من طرف حزب علي
عبد الله صالح حزب مؤتمر الشعب العام
وخمسين في المئه من المقاعد الخمسه هي
يعني ما بين حزب الاصلاح
حزب اشتراكي واحزاب واحزاب اخرى كان
الاتفاق في اطار مؤتمر الحوار الوطني ان
يتم دمج الاطراف الاخرى معناها الحوثيين
والحراك الجنوبي وهذا لم يتم اسر الرئيس
واصرت الاحزاب الموجوده في الحكومه على
ابعادهم رغم انه كان هناك توافق في مؤتمر
الحوار الوطني على حكومه شراكه هذا الحوار
الوطني كما ذكرت ادى الى توقيع اتفاقيه
السلم والشراكه عام 2014 لكنك استقلت
بعدها مباشره لماذا اولا حوار الوطني دام
عشره اشهر وقبل هذا سته اشهر المرحله
تحضيريه وتم الخروج بخلاصات بمخرجات
لهذه المخرجات كانت القاعده الاساسيه
لصياغه دستور اليمن الجديد لكن اللي حصل
ومباشره بعد انتهاء مؤتمر الحوار الوطني
لم يتم تنفيذ عدد من المخرجات
يا جماعه كلها يعني كل الاطراف كانت متفقه
ما الذي تغير بعد ذلك الاراده السياسيه في
نهايه المطاف هل لعبه اطراف خارجيه هنا
السؤال هل لعبت اطراف خارجيه برايك اي
تغييرات ربما انت كنت موجود على الارض انا
كنت موجود هذه مشاكل كانت مشاكل ما بين
يمنيين الخارج لم يكن له دخل في هذا كان
الحوار حوار يمني يقوده اليمنيون بتسير
متواضع من طرف الامم المتحده كانت هناك
مشكله اخرى كذلك كانت هناك زياده في
الاسعار
وقررت الحكومه بضغط من صندوق النقد الدولي
والبنك الدولي رفع الدعم على المشتقات
النفطيه وهذا ادى الى ارتفاع مباشر الحوت
استغلوا هذا وبداوا يعني بمظاهرات
وانتقادات للحكومه الى اخره لكن من بعد
تضح ان هدف كان شيء اخر ليس يعني الارتفاع
الاحتجاج على ارتفاع الاسعار
لما دخل الحوثيون الى صنعاء لم تكن هناك
مقاومه بمجموعات التي دخلت الى صنعه كانت
صغيره لم تكن بالالاف كانت عشرات فقط
الرئيس سابق على عبد الله صالح يعني اتضح
ان كان له تاثير كبير في الجيش واعطاها
اوامر
للضباط الموالين ليه لان لا يقاوموا
التمدد الحوثيين ودخولهم الى صنعاء كما ان
هناك اطراف في السلطه كانت ترى لانه دخول
الحوتيين سيكون مفيد سيدخل ويتخلص من
الاخوان المسلمين ومن جامعه الايمان ومن
قيادات حزب الاصلاح
وسيرجعه الى الى صدى تضع فيما بعد انه هو
هذا كان تفكير خاطئ
وساذج جدا كانت هناك خيانه كان هناك تواطئ
كان هناك كانت هناك بلاده سياسيه بصراحه
عند البعض في السلطه مثلا اكبر الاحزاب
الموجوده انا تاكدي في اليمن حزب الاصلاح
قرر عدم مقاومه الحوتيين وابلغ قياده
الاصلاح على انهم لن يقفوا في وجه
الحوثيين لما دخلوا لان هذا كان سيكون
مصيده لهم وهذا اظن فعلا كان ممكن يعني
تقييمه هذا كان صحيح اربطك علاقه قويه
للحوثيين كان اول اهم الشهر الاول
مهم بالنسبه لي لما دخلوا الحوتين والحفاظ
على حياه وسلامه الرئيس رئيس تما وضعه
تحتها الاقامه الاجباريه كان وضع صعب
وكانت
الوسيط ما بين وما بين الحوثيين
كان الهدف هو اطلاق يعني العمل على اطلاق
سراح الرئيس كذلك عدد كبير من اعضاء
الحكومه من ضمنهم رئيس الوزراء الاخ خالد
البحاح كان هو كذلك تحت الاقامه الاجباريه
وكنت اعمل يعني اقوم بالمساعي الحميده من
اجل حل هذه المشكله لاطلاق فعلا تم اطلاق
صراح
رئيس الحكومه وجميع الوزراء فشل جمال بن
عمر في حل ازمه اليمن فشل اليمنيون في حل
مشاكلهم جمال بن عمر قام بمهمه وساطه مهمه
تيسير حوار وطني لم يحاول اي احد ان يوقف
هذا الحل العسكري ولا اي دوله ولا اي طرف
خلف الكواليسات وانه يعني لما بدات هذه
الحرب بالنسبه للدول الرئيسيه الموجوده في
المجلس الامن اصبحوا ينظر لليمن على انه
بزنس في الحقيقه لانه فرصه فرصه لبيع
السلاح واصبح تنافس ما بين دول المجلس
الامن الدول الخمسه اصبحت تنافس ما بينهم
على بيع السلاح وعلى التوقيع على عقود
كبيره جدا خياليه تعقدت الامور بشكل كبير
جدا بالتالي ماذا عن الحلول لو كنت اليوم
انت على راس عملك بطلت منك ان تعطيني نقاط
قد تساهم بشكل او باخر في جد حل لازمه
اليمن ما هي تلك الحلول اولا على الدول
الخارجيه
دوله دخلت في شؤون اليمن ان ترفع يدها على
اليمن لا يمكن ان تكون هناك حكومه او
ترتيب جديد بدون مشاركه الاخوان المسلمين
بجانب الحوثيين لا يمكن ان يسب الامور في
اليمن اذا لم تتم معالجه القضيه الجنوبيه
عمر ستاره الحرب في بيته ليعيش في عالم
اخر عالم ينصت فيه لصوت الموسيقى بدلا من
عزيز الرصاص والنقاشات الحاده في بيئه
عنوانها السلام يستعيد قواه ويغذي روحه
هنا لكن يبقى الحنين للمغرب قائما فيشبعه
بالطبق المغربي الشهير الطاجن حيث دعاني
بشغلك في السياسه قديش بعدك عن العيله انا
الان اني اتاسف كون انه
تفرقت كتير العمل
وسافرت كتير يعني مر وقت يعني بسرعه يعني
كبروا الاطفال هم في الجامعه
الابناء في المجتمع الغربي بتكون صعبه
نوعا ما ولو انه والدتهم امريكيه تزوجت من
امريكيه لازم تحاول ترجع فيهم العادات
والتقاليد العربيه المغربيه اكيد يعني
تعلموا في وقت مبكر يعني العادات المغربيه
سافروا الى المغرب وتعرفوا على اقاربهم في
المغرب
وهم فخرون يعني جدا يعني
بجذورهم
المغربيه اكيد
تعرفت على زوجتك التقينا في اطلنطا لما
كنت تشتغل مع
الرئيس
التقينا بالصدفه
ومن بعد سنتين تزوجنا في اطلنطا
الان بعد التقاعد دكتور لا تفكر بالعوده
الى المغرب انا لم اتقاعد
ساشتغل دائما مادام يعني صحته تسمح بهذا
الان
انا بصدد تطوير مشروع يعني بدا منذ سنه
مركز ابحاث ودراسات مختص في قضايا حل
النزاعات والوساطات والدعم الحوارات
الوطنيه الى اخره
بدات هذا المشروع مع مجموعه من
الزملاء كلهم اشتغلوا معي في الامم
المتحده
والهدف من هذا هو
تطوير القدرات المحليه والوطنيه والمستوى
الاقليمي العربي يعني المستوى الوطن
العربي
لانه في نهايه المطاف جميع الوسطات
الموجوده هي كلها وسطات تاتي من الخارج
يعني سكان المنطقه يجب ان يتحمل المسؤوليه
وكذلك المؤتمر اقليميه مثل التعاون يعني
حان الوقت ان يبنوا قدرات يعني تجعلهم
يعني فاعلين
في هذا المجال
[موسيقى]
انت كنت دبلوماسي بارع في مسيرتك لكن ماذا
عن المنزل لابد انه في الحياه الزوجيه
يعني تقع بعض الخلافات هل كنت الشخص
الدبلوماسي في المنزل ايضا دائما تحل
المشاكل في البيت
دائما ضروري يعني الحل النزاعات يعني
الاطفال احيانا
واحيانا قلت كنت اقول لاولادي لانه انتم
اصعب من يعني
لما يكون نزاع ما بين
الطفل واخر حول لعبه حول شيء
يعني اتدخل كالدبلوماسي للوساطه واحيانا
يعني يصعب يعني حل المشكله لكن على اي حال
انا حاولت ما امكن انني ازرع فيهم يعني
يروح التساؤل
والروح النقديه
ونجحت في هذا الى حد ما
يعني انا الان استمتع بالنقاش الاحداث ما
يجري في العالم مع اطفالي
ان كلهم يعني لهم
ميول يعني تتبع ما يحصل في العالم
والسياسه وبالاخره تحاول دائما ان يكونوا
بعيدين كليا عن مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
اقول حتى الاعلام لم يظهروا بالاعلام
يعني حياتي الشخصيه لم تظهر في الاعلام
وما ظهر ليس له علاقه بالواقع نحن محظوظين
احنا اول مره يدخل يعني يدخل الاعلان الى
منزله
لا اكيد يعني عائلتي لم تكون يعني في
الاعلام وانا سعيد يعني انني جنبتم هذا
هذا الجانب هل انت نادم على اي شيء في
الماضي وكيف تنظر للمستقبل
اي شيء يعني شيء واحد فقط وانني لم اقضي
الوقت الكافي مع اطفالي لكن من غير هذا
اظن حياتي كانت
مغامره من البدايه الى النهايه
[موسيقى]
وعرفت يعني تطورات كثيره لم اخطط لحياتي
كيف
لمسيرتي في الحياه كانت يعني تجارب مختلفه
لكن اغنت يعني شخصيتي ومساري
[موسيقى]
اهلا وسهلا
جمال بن عمر
[موسيقى]
احيانا تمضين الحياه الى مسارات لم نخطط
لها
لكننا نحتاج لاختيار الزاويه المضيئه
والسير نحوها
[موسيقى]
طريقي مع جمال بن عمر انتهى لكنني ساكمل
الطريقه مترقبه لقاء شخصا اخر مع جانب اخر
جديد
[موسيقى]